TONIGHT BUT DOES HE THINK ABOUT
THE FUTURE?
>> WE CAN NOW MAKE A MAJOR
PROMISE.
CNN PROJECTS THAT CALIFORNIA
GOVERNOR AFGHAN NEWSOM DEFEATS
THE RECALL AND WILL SERVE OUT
HIS TERM.
DODGING WHAT WOULD HAVE BEEN A
SERIOUS BLOW TO HIS PARTY AND
HIS CAREER IN ONE OF THE
NATION'S BIGGEST AND BLUEST
STATES.
AGAIN, CNN PROJECTS THAT GAVIN
NEWSOM, THE INCUMBENT GOVERNOR,
DEFEATS THE RECALL AND WILL
REMAIN GOVERNOR OF CALIFORNIA.
DANA BASH, THIS IS A MUCH
EARLIER NIGHT THAN WE THOUGHT.
IT IS A GOOD NIGHT FOR THE
DEMOCRATS.
A GOOD NIGHT FOR GAVIN NEWSOM.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
A RECALL IS BY DEFINITION A
REFERENDUM ON THE GOVERNOR.
AND WHAT THE GOVERNOR'S AIDES
ARE SAYING THAT THEY REALLY FEEL
THEY DID RIGHT IS MAKE SHOULD
NOT A REFERENDUM ON HIM BUT A
REFERENDUM ON WHAT WOULD HAPPEN
IF HE'S NOT THERE.
WHAT WOULD HAPPEN IF A TRUMP
REPUBLICAN TOOK OVER?
WHAT WOULD HAPPEN TO PEOPLE WITH
THEIR LIVES WITH REGARD TO
SOCIAL ISSUES, AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY, COVID?
AND THEY HAD LARRY ELDER, THE
LEADING REPUBLICAN, AS FOIL AND
ALSO, REPUBLICAN GOVERNORS OF
OTHER STATES FOR GAVIN NEWSOM TO
POINT TO TO SAY, DO YOU WANT
CALIFORNIA TO END UP LIKE
FLORIDA OR TEXAS WITH REGARD TO
MASK MANDATES, NOT ALLOWING
THEM, OR EVEN NOT EVEN PUSHING
VACCINES?
>> NO DOUBT ABOUT IT.
A GOOD NIGHT FOR DEMOCRATS.
THEY RAN A DEMOCRATIC PLAY BOOK
AND WON.
STILL SOME WARNING SIGNS FOR
DEMOCRATS.
THERE IS SO MUCH UNEASE IN THE
COUNTRY AROUND COVID STILL.
AROUND THE ECONOMY, AROUND
CLIMATE CHANGE.
AND GAVIN NEWSOM HAS TO GOVERN
AND DEMOCRATS HAVE TO GOVERN AND
THEY HAVE TO APPROVE THAT THEY
CAN SOLVE THESE PROBLEMS.
THAT IS THE BIG TEST, RIGHT?
HE DIDN'T RUN ON HIS RECORD.
HE RAN AGAINST TRUMPISM, AGAINST
ELDER, HE RAN AGAINST DeSANTIS.
CAN HE FIX THE HOMELESS PROBLEM
IN CALIFORNIA WHICH IS SUCH A
BIG ISSUE FOR SO MANY PEOPLE?
SO THAT'S STILL THE QUESTION FOR
DEMOCRATS.
WHAT IS THEIR MESSAGE ABOUT
THEIR PARTY AND THEIR RECORD OF
ACCOMPLISHMENT IN.
>> AND LET ME ASK YOU.
I'VE SEEN IT SAID IN THE LAST
WEEK BY DEMOCRATIC AIDES, AND I
WOULD UNDERSTAND IF YOU AGREE.
THE BEST THING THAT HAPPENED TO
GAVIN NEWSOM WAS LARRY ELDER
SHOOTING TO THE TOP OF THE
POLLS.
>> YEAH.
I'VE HAD BOTH REPUBLICANS AND
DEMOCRATS SAY THAT TO ME OVER
THE COURSE OF THE LAST DAY.
I SPOKE TO STRATEGISTS FOR THE
RIFLE REPUBLICANS AND THEY SAY
LARRY ELDER WAS THE BEST THING
EVER HAD A TO GAVIN NEWSOM.
I THINK THE BIG PICTURE, AS JOHN
WAS SO CAREFUL TO POINT OUT.
THESE NUMBERS ARE NOT FINAL BUT
THE MARGIN THIS EARLY IN THE
NIGHT IS HUGE.
BIGGER THAN MANY EXPECTED.
CERTAINLY MORE THAN MY SOURCES
EXPECTED IT TO BE.
I THINK THAT SHOWS THAT YOU
DEMOCRATS ARE REALLY ENGAGED OR
THAT YOU CAN ENGAGE THEM.
THEY HAVEN'T TUNED OUT FROM THE
NEWS AFTER FOUR YEARS OF DONALD
TRUMP.
THEY ARE STILL AFRAID OF THAT
GOVERNANCE OF LIVING THAT WAY
AGAIN.
THAT THERE IS A WAY TO ACTIVATE
THAT INSTINCT.
SOMETIMES WHEN YOU WIN
ELECTIONS, YOUR VOTERS SIT BACK
AND SAYERING IS FINE.
I DON'T NEED TO GET ENGAGED OR
GET TO THE POLLS.
THAT DIDN'T HAPPEN HERE.
>> SOME OF THE POLICY POSITIONS
THAT WERE PART OF LARRY ELDER'S
DECADES LONG TIME IN RADIO,
DOING TALK RADIO, BEING
PROVOCATIVE.
THE JOB OF SOMEBODY IN TALK
RADIO.
BUNDLE NECESSARILY APPEALING TO
VOTERS.
ESPECIALLY NOT IN CALIFORNIA.
ON POSING MINIMUM WAGE, OPPOSING
LEGAL ABORTION, AND DURING THE
COVID PANDEMIC, NOT ANTI-VACCINE
BUT DIDN'T SEEM LIKE SOMEBODY --
>> HE SAID HE GOT IT.
>> HE WOULD NOT IMPOSE MANDATES
AS GOVERNOR NEWSOM HAS ON HEALTH
CARE WORKERS AND TEACHERS.
SOMEBODY WHO IS AGAINST MASKING
IN SCHOOLS.
SOMEBODY WHO HAS VOICED ONLY
SIGNIFICANCE TO KIDS GETTING
VACCINATED.
THIS IS NOT A STATE THAT WANTED
TO HEAR THAT MESSAGE.
>> THAT'S ONE OF THE QUESTIONS
THAT WE WILL SEE BEING ASKED AND
THAT WILL BE A TEST THAT STATES
ACROSS THE COUNTRY ARE GOING TO
BE LOOKING AT.
AND THAT IS ABOUT THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY.
YES, IN 2003, ARNOLD
SCHWARZENEGGER WON FOR A LOT OF
REASONS.
NOT THE LEAST OF WHICH WAS HE
WAS ONE OF THE BIGGEST MOVIE
STARS IN THE WORLD BUST ALSO
BECAUSE HE WAS NOT A SORT OF
BASE CONSERVATIVE.
THAT DOESN'T WORK IN -- IT
DOESN'T WORK IN CALIFORNIA.
IT WOULDN'T NECESSARILY WORK IN
EVEN A PURPLY STATE.
WHEN YOU SEE THAT THERE WERE
OTHER REPUBLICANS ON THE BALLOT
LIKE THE MAYOR OF SAN DIEGO, WHO
ARE MAYBE MORE FITTING FOR A
PLACE LIKE CALIFORNIA, AND THEY
DIDN'T STAND A CHANCE BECAUSE
THAT'S NOT WHERE THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY IS, IT IS A WARNING SIGN
FOR REPUBLICANS WHEN YOU LOOK AT
THEIR NATIONAL ABILITY.
>> THIS IS THE SECOND ELECTION
THAT WE'VE HAD AFTER THE -- WE
HAD THE FLEXES GEORGIA WHERE YOU
HAD CANDIDATES COMING OUT AND
SAYING, DON'T TRUST THE SYSTEM.
YOUR VOTE WON'T BE COUNTED.
BEFORE THIS ELECTION WE HAD
LARRY ELDER ALREADY SAYING, YOUR
VOTE WON'T BE KOUTD.
THERE'S ALREADY FRAUD.
I WAS TALKING TO ONE REPUBLICAN.
WE'VE ALL COVERED THAT
CALIFORNIA REPUBLICANS HAVE BEEN
VOTING BY MAIL FOR YEARS.
DECADES EVEN IN A WAY THAT HAD
THEM EXTRAORDINARILY COMFORTABLE
WITH THE SYSTEM.
AND NOW ALL OF A SUDDEN, THESE
DOUBTS HAVE BEEN SOWN.
AND REPUBLICANS THINK THAT MAYBE
HURT THEM AND MAYBE PART OF
MARGIN AS WELL.
IF YOU THINK ABOUT HOW THAT
APPLIES ACROSS THE MAP, IT IS A
REAL PROBLEM FOR REPUBLICANS AND
MANAGER, OBVIOUSLY, BUT ALSO FOR
REPUBLICANS.
>> I THINK WE'LL SEE IN IT OTHER
RACES.
YOU THINK ABOUT THE VIRGINIA
GOVERNOR'S RACE.
THE WAY IN WHICH TERRY McAULIFFE
IS TRYING TO PAIN THE PERSON AS
A TRUMPIST.
THAT WILL BE THE BIG QUESTION.
HOW POTENT IS TRUMP AND TRUMPISM
IN 2022?
WE SAW HERE THAT RUNNING AGAINST
TRUMPISM WAS VERY EASY IN A
DEMOCRATIC STATE.
WE'LL SEE HOW THAT PLAYS OUT IN
THESE HOUSE RACES, IN THE OTHER
GOVERNOR RACES AS WELL.
>> VERY DIFFERENT DYNAMIC.
>> WE ARE WAITING TO HEAR FROM
DR. GAVIN NEWSOM.
WE'LL BRING THOSE COMMENTS TO
YOU LIVE.
WHAT LESSONS ARE CLEAR AT THIS
POINT?
>> CALIFORNIA IS BEHAVING
POLITICALLY THE WAY IT IS DRAWN.
THE MAP IS COMING THROUGH.
DO I CAUTION THIS IS A BLOWOUT
AND THE NUMBER PROBABLY SHRINK.
WE KNOW FROM LAST YEAR'S VOTE BY
MAIL ELECTION, REPUBLICANS WILL
VOTE LATE, MAYBE EVEN IN PERSON
TODAY.
IT IS CLEAR.
IT WILL BE A BIG BLUE VICTORY IN
A BLUE STATE.
>> WHAT DO YOU EXPECT TO HEAR
FROM NEWSOM TONIGHT?
IT DOESN'T SEEM LIKE, HOW
CELEBRATORY WOULD IT BE?
>> I'M SURE HE'S BEING CAUTIONED
NOT TO CELEBRATE.
HE'S NOT EXACTLY KNOWN FOR
INTROSPECTION.
I THINK YOU WILL SEE A RATHER
BRASH ACCEPTANCE SPEECH.
OR A VICTORY SPEECH, I SUPPOSE.
>> HE'LL BE WELL SERVED TO GET
ON QUICKLY AND DO THE WORK OF
THE PEOPLE.
>> I THINK HE'S BEEN RUMBLED BY
THIS EXPERIENCE.
YOUR SUCCESS GIVES YOU
CONFIDENCE.
YOUR SETBACKS GIVE YOU
CHARACTER.
HE WAS LOOKING DOWN THE BARREL
OF HIS CAREER BEING OVER.
TOWED FIND SOMETHING IN HIMSELF.
YOU SAW THAT IN HIM.
HE CONNECTED WITH THE
GRASSROOTS.
I THINK YOU WILL SEE SOMETHING
GOOD FROM HIM TONIGHT.
WHAT I WILL SAY IS, TONIGHT IT
IS FEAR TIMES FEAR EQUALS
FRUSTRATION.
THE REPUBLICANS WERE AFRAID OF
GAVIN.
NOT JUST BECAUSE OF COVID.
HE WAS DOING STUFF ON UNIVERSAL
PRE-K.
A LOT OF STUFF THAT SCARED THE
REPUBLICANS.
THEN THE DEMOCRATS GOT SCARED OF
LARRY ELDER.
NOT JUST LARRY ELDER.
THE REPUBLICAN STUFF ON CHOICE
THAT THEY'VE BEEN DOING, ON
VOTING THAT THEY'VE BEEN DOING,
BEING NOWHERE ON CLIMATE CHANGE.
IT SCARED DEMOCRATS.
YOU HAVE REPUBLICANS SCARED OF
GAVIN AND DEMOCRATS GOT SCARED
OF LARRY ELDER.
MOST CALIFORNIANS ARE FRUSTRATED
BECAUSE WE WASTED ALL THIS TIME
AND ALL THIS MONEY AND WE'RE IN
THE SAME PLACE WITH NO PROGRESS.
>> $270 MILLION.
$276 MILLION FOR WHAT?
>> YOU TALK ABOUT NEWSOM BEING
HUMBLED.
THE FACT IS IT WAS THAT LACK OF
HUMILITY THAT WOUND HIM UP IN
THIS BATTLE.
HE WENT TO A RESTAURANT IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE PANDEMIC AND
DEFIED HIS OWN GUIDANCE.
IT WAS REALLY THE JET FUEL
BEHIND THE MOVEMENT TO RECALL
HIM.
IT TURNED OUT TO BE THE MOST
EXPENSIVE MEAL ANYBODY EVER HAD.
TOWED SPEND $80 MILLION TO WIN
THIS RACE.
THE DESSERT WAS PRETTY GOOD FOR
HIM HERE.
AND PEOPLE WILL LOOK AT THIS.
I THINK DEMOCRATS ARE GOING TO
LOOK AT THIS AND SAY, IS THIS A
FORMULA?
AND YOU'RE RIGHT.
IT IS NOT JUST ABOUT VACCINES.
THAT CLEARLY WORKED FOR HIM
HERE.
BUT THERE IS THIS TRUMP TINGED
EXTREMISM.
DEMOCRATS GOING INTO THE
MID-TERMS, THEY'RE GOING TO BE I
THINK IN A VERY DIFFICULT
POSITION TO HOLD THE HOUSE,
PERHAPS THE HELD TO SENATE.
THE ONE THING THEY GOT GOING FOR
THEM IS REPUBLICANS.
AND THE LESSON HERE IS,
REPUBLICAN EXTREMISM DOES NOT
SELL OUTSIDE THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY.
>> THIS IS MITCH McCONNELL'S BIG
CONCERN WITH THE PRIMARIES THAT
LIE AHEAD WHERE HE WILL NEED
CANDIDATES THAT ARE NOT -- OR
HERSHEL WALKER.
WHAT IS PLAYING OUT HERE IF
CALIFORNIA IS THE DMEN SFRAGS A
TRUMPIAN STYLE CANDIDATE CANNOT
GROW THE BASE, RIGHT?
YOU CAN'T EXPAND BEYOND, IN THIS
CASE, THE FRINGE IN CALIFORNIA.
WE'RE ALREADY OUTNUMBERED 2-1.
THIS IS EXACTLY WHY MITCH
McCONNELL HAS ENGAGED.
>> THAT'S A PROBLEM.
WE HAD A POLL RECENTLY WHICH
SAID, 16